[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Подніпров'я та Запоріжжя
Нікополь]
Арт-майстерня «Африка» —
це творчий майданчик
для втілення творчих ідей
і особистих поглядів людини.
Кожен учасник, що приходить сюди...
[Татяна Максимчук,
скульпторка]
...це і діти, і дорослі,
знаходять на свій запит те, що шукають.
Головна наша концепція —
це самореалізація.
Оскільки людина індивідуальна,
ми надаємо можливість
цій індивідуальності проявитися.
Сім років тому я приїхав до Нікополя.
[В'ячеслав Гуденок,
скульптор]
Приїхав у відрядження на два роки з Києва.
Мені треба було по роботі
познайомитися з творчою людиною.
Мені треба було зробити дизайн приміщення.
І мені порадили Тетяну.
Коли я з нею зустрівся
і почав спілкуватися по роботі,
я зрозумів, що ця людина
поділяє мої погляди на життя,
сповнена творчістю,
розвиває у дітей творчість.
І я сказав, що хочу навчатися,
хочу в неї випробувати
деякі творчі моменти.
І ми з нею почали займатися.
І ось наше навчання з нею переросло
в творчий союз.
На той момент я був
керівником швейного підприємства
і до творчої професії
не мав жодного відношення.
Я почала займатися творчістю
тому що зрозуміла,
що мене ця тема дуже приваблює,
що це моє і я хочу бути й жити
тільки так. І крапка.
Мені дуже подобається вести за собою дітей.
Скажімо так, по життю я лише цим займаюсь.
Я розумію, що займаюся своєю справою.
Нам дуже хотілось, щоб художники
виходили за межі своїх майстернь
і показували свої роботи людям.
Таким чином ми організували й
проводили вуличні галереї.
І це вже наше досягнення,
досягнення міста,
що в місті зробили скульптурний парк.
Він ще невеликий,
але вже є.
Там стоять скульптури,
котрі були зроблені протягом
останніх двох симпозиумів
в місті Нікополь.
Ось це наша «групіровка»,
творче групування.
Хлопці й дівчата, що прийшли колись давно
до нас в майстерню ще дітьми.
Вони активно приймають участь
у творчому житті міста.
Усі костюми ми створюємо власноруч.
Ось цей шолом вироблений зі шкіри,
Клепки робили своїми руками,
формували роги.
Спочатку створювали паперовий макет,
а потім вже робили зі шкіри.
Ми вирішили трошки почудити в місті.
І вирішили створити
скульптурний перформанс.
Я запропонував хлопцям й дівчатам
подумати, що вони хотіли б створити.
І дав їм найпростіший матеріал —
дерев'яні рейки та цвяхи.
І вони створили свої роботи
заввишки 2-3 метри.
Вони навіть місяць простояли.
Це взагалі щось надзвичайне.
Бо, зазвичай, вандали
вносять свою лепту.
А це в них навіть рука не піднялася.
Наприклад, робота Карена —
це була рука.
Людська рука, що стояла у парку
і символізувала відповідальність людини
за все, що вона коїть в світі.
Для того, щоб глина стала міцною
і була скульптурою,
котра може вписатися в міський простір,
вона має бути запечена.
І запечена при високій температурі,
не менше 1000 градусів.
Вогонь, проходячи крізь скульптуру,
щонайменше 8 годин,
пропікає цю скульптуру.
Поверхню скульптури ми огортаємо
і скульптура гріється, гріється, гріється,
сягаючи температури білого каління.
Тоді вона запеклася і готова вже.
І коли скульптура вже готова,
ми вату розкриваємо.
І ось ця вогненароджена скульптура
постає перед людьми.
Вона наче народжується з полум'я.
Ось це і називається вогняна скульптура.
— Ми мріємо провести в скіфських степах...
— Це поки що секрет.
Але ми збираємося робити тут «Burningman».
У нікопольській місцевості.
Вона як раз підходить за станом,
за температурою, за широтою.
З одного боку, це край козацької слави.
А з іншого, якщо забігти ще раніше,
це край скіфської культури.
На мою думку, скіфська культура була основоположницею.
Вона вплинула на всі наступні культури,
що були на цій території.
Ми пропонуємо скульпторам і керамістам,
що приїжджають на цей симпозіум,
подумати про своє місце в світі,
про відношення до скіфської культури,
і надати свій погляд
через ось ці вогняні скульптури.
Як корінний нікопольчанин,
що народився в Чернігові, жив в Києві,
а зараз творить у Нікополі,
я хочу сказати, що ті,
хто сюди приїжджають, вони щасливці.
В цьому місті відсутня метушня.
Це місто дозволяє людині зрозуміти,
чого вона бажає насправді.
Коли живеш у Києві,
дуже багато моментів,
які тебе відволікають щосекунди.
Тут цього нема.
Можливо це погано,
але для мене — добре.
Це дозволило мені
зайнятися творчістю.
Це дозволило мені глибоко
переосмислити свій погляд на світ.
Спекотне сонце, степ бескрайній,
запах полину,
вони дають специфіку якоїсь вольності,
якою дихали скіфи, потім — козаки,
те, чим ми зараз дихаємо.
Ось це для мене Нікополь.
[Автор проекту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Oператори
Микола Носок, Євген Лях]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режиссер
Микола Носок]
[Звукорежиссер
Павел Пашко]
[Mонтажерка
Анна Воробйова]
[Mузика
Sasha Boole, ТеЯРем, Шосте Чуття]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]